you probably not entered the UFC but we
need to talk about it real quick yeah
yeah do it
I'm sure Kallen do you hang with
calendar yeah my most of my UFC viewing
experiences are through Bryan Bryan
Callen yeah Ryan's one of my brother
yeah you tell you've done fighting on
the kid yet uh-huh yeah you know it some
of my favorites yeah recently different
we could go to a nicer place we want to
stay at home lower overhead but last
Saturday's fights the I honestly three
really good one yes yes the greatest
card they've ever made I believe and the
biggest upset in the history of UFC in
my opinion johanna eun-chae check
getting knocked up by rose namajunas in
the first round was what did i do babe
you were there on the ground and stay
there crying you ran around for a while
good while who she did you I did I ran a
circle my fell on the ground
good jumping jacks don't be Jackson your
brother started like hugging each other
and flailing yeah yeah we did that bold
move
yeah the old this is the Korean way why
is it an upset our favorite fighter is a
woman okay so there's this guy I'll tell
you why my friend yeah I'm glad you
asked me yeah she was 14 to now
undefeated
yeah that's toughness and and she was
just rude I mean I mean it's like when
she won the belt right it was like an
adult fighting a five-year-old kid I
mean that's the difference of skill of
her 14th fight of no no no no no no what
so Johanna is 14 - no okay
but when she got fought for the belt the
championship belt yeah she was like 7 -
no ok ok
and when she flosses champion she
destroyed her the path that point was
like oh my god she's levels above
everyone right and this group that she
fought last Saturday Rose was 7 and 4
was a record she had lost a bunch yeah
she was young yeah and she there was a
what was that 99 to 1 chance
chance to shoot oh wow yeah she was a
crazy episode a +400 and the end the way
they said the only way she could win is
to choke her out if she got real super
creative in jail yeah one minute within
one minute yeah knocked her out yeah
champion our girl that everyone thought
was one of the pound-for-pound best
fighters on planet earth yeah with men
including yeah yeah not just men in
general he's one of the greatest Wow and
this girl from Denver just walked in
there and she [ __ ] took care of
business and it was shocking you know
it's like you know it's insane Ronda
Rousey hosted after she lost that fight
oh wow and it was interesting to hear
talk about it because she said what
happened was very early on one of the
hits knocked out her vision so she had
no depth perception dance so it's like
sometimes it's just something like that
like yeah you got she got a fist to just
the brow and it and it she was just
seeing white in this eye and then had no
depth perception is like she couldn't
gauge is what you know how she told it
and and that was why you know it was it
was over so fast for her to wow so it
feels like when you're kicking and
punching and hitting in the face yeah
really anybody's game you know what
that's exactly exactly yeah yeah because
and that proved it Saturday because I
was obsessed with Johanna in fact I I
still am but I was just like title seven
times this girl did it it was a saw
shocking and then like GSP coming back
after four years pretty good another
Canadian we love okay okay and then you
know TJ Dillashaw
doing what he did or care business yeah
it was just a great night of bonding and
it was nice it feels very close to the
McGregor fight right is it yeah does it
feel like a big event I close to me
about what you have
what's up in his little bits a little
bit this guy right here right here is
one of those kinds of white dudes right
cgw yeah yeah that is just concerned
five in any situation
this [ __ ] could be like in the
polar icecaps yeah I mean yeah like
talking with a scientist and could talk
about shell-like shelving you want to
focus you want to focus on warming your
chest right because your arms will take
care you can get what ms-13 and they're
like oh [ __ ] games you should have
had it you know what you know what kind
of whitey is gee I've said it before
what GW I'm good Noah Schindler white
okay savior the border been gift Harry
killable round of applause everybody
thank you so much everybody
[Music]